So I'm going to leave you with a few
very simple prescriptions in terms of
what what we can do so we can stop
talking about mothers and start talking
about parents every time you want to say
mother,
stop.
Say parents and children,
parents and family stopped talking about
daughters and start talking about
caregivers are in Britain,
carers,
carers for parents,
whether their sons or daughters stopped
talking about fathers and start talking
about earners or providers.
Both men and women
start assuming that every everybody,
men and women want some combination of
the ability to invest in themselves and
to invest in others,
everyone and that all workers,
all employees will have caregiving
responsibilities at some point in their
lives and a competitive effective
workplace.
Efficient,
productive will make room for that kind
of care and start assuming that
investing in others is every bit as
important and rewarding and valuable as
investing in ourselves.
And finally,
I don't think I would call it equalism.
I think a Galitary aneurysm is better,
but maybe isms are not the way to go.
What we are looking for is a world in
which we don't assume everyone is the
same,
absolutely not,
but a world in which our assumptions
about who someone is and what they want
and what they can achieve and what their
potential is is not tied to their sex or
their gender or their sexual orientation
any more than it is tied to the shape of
their features or the color of their
skin.
Thank you.